The first order of business in this
level is downloading the course code and
ensuring your development
environment is up and running.
Next, we'll learn how Live GDX gives
you access to some of the important
capabilities of whatever platform your
game is running on, including logging,
graphics and file access.
Then, we'll learn all about
drawing sprites and textures and
the differences between those two terms.
We'll also learn a few tricks,
such as creating a stretchy
sprite called a nine-patch.
And combining multiple
sprites into animations.
Finally, a big game with a lot of
sprites can run into problems trying to
load a ton of different files.
So, we'll learn how to pack all of
our sprites into a giant image called
a texture atlas that we
can load all at once.
But first, the course code.
Let's go get it.